chào các
bạn à video này sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn các
thao tác trên đối tượng hình vẽ hay còn
gọi là s và cụ thể trong cái bài này
chúng ta sẽ vẽ một cái sơ đồ tổ chức gồm
có các đối tượng như thế này và bây giờ
bắt đầu chúng ta vào thẻ Insert chọn lên
set và sau đó chọn kiểu đội tượng Chúng
ta sẽ tìm tìm ví dụ đây dưới này chúng
ta nhắp chuột vào xong chúng ta quét lên
trên màn hình Chúng ta có được đối tượng
hình vẽ Và bây giờ chúng ta thấy cái
phần Cuộn này này phần cuộn ở phía bên
trái hoặc bên phải này nó lớn hơn thì
chúng ta nhấp vào nút màu vàng để chúng
ta kéo đây kéo Sau đó chúng ta thay đổi
kích cợ một chút đấy Và bây giờ tiếp tục
là chúng ta đổi màu thì chúng ta vào qu
Style này chúng ta chọn màu cho nó rồi
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ gõ vào cơ cấu tổ
chức chúng ta chỉ việc nhắp chuột vào và
gõ vào thôi cơ cấu tổ
chức rồi thì do nó không đủ đồ rộng
Chúng ta mở rộng ra một chút đấy
rồi đó là chúng ta vẽ xong cái đối tượng
tiêu đề tiếp theo là chúng ta vẽ đội
tượng giám đốc công ty thì chúng ta lại
vào Insert SH và chúng ta chọn đối tượng
hình vẽ này mình th document nhắp chược
Sau đó chúng ta quét lên trên màn hình
đấy thì tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ vẽ cái
đường thẳng này xuống thì chúng ta vào
Insert set chúng ta chọn Line nhá và bắt
đầu từ đây này là nó ở giữa chúng ta vẽ
thẳng xuống và chúng ta vẽ thì chúng ta
kéo chuột theo phương thẳng đứng nha
Tránh trường hợp chúng ta kéo xẹo quá
thì khi mà chúng ta vẽ bị xo á thì nó
thì tốt nhất là chúng ta sẽ nhắc xóa đi
và chúng ta vẽ
lại chúng ta cứ vẽ như thế đã sau này
chúng ta có thể điều chỉnh tiếp tục là
chúng ta sẽ vẽ cái hình chữ nhật là các
ph đất thì chúng ta vào
Insert và chọn rle ở đây chữ nhật sau đó
chúng ta vẽ lên
à tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ vẽ cái đường
từ cái đường thẳng này nè qua bên r Go
thì chúng ta sẽ chọn Insert set và chọn
Line và chúng ta vẽ
qua
à bây giờ tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ vẽ
phòng kế hoạch và phòng chăm sóc khách
hàng thì cái hình chữ nhật đấy á thì
chúng ta không vẽ nữa mà chúng ta sẽ
copy xuống và cách copy là chúng ta sẽ
nhấn à à phím Ctrl giữ vậy và nhấp kéo
là chúng ta copy được ví dụ đây chúng ta
nhắp chột vào nhấn giữ Ctrl nhấp kéo
xuống đó là thao tác
copy Nha và bây giờ tương tự cái Line
chúng ta cũng vẽ Ngang
Qua và chúng ta vẽ thẳng qua bên này
luôn và chúng ta lại tiến hành là copy
cái hình dữ nhật này qua đây chúng ta
không vẽ lại nữa vì vẽ lại có thể kích
cỡ nó không bằng nhau tiếp tục chúng ta
chọn ba đối tượng hình chữ nhật hai hình
chữ nhật và một cái l bằng cách nhấn vào
giữ
shift sau đó lần lượt nhắp chuột vào các
đối tượng chúng ta nhấn giữ Ctrl để copy
xuống để chúng ta có được những cái cặp
An vẽ ở phía
dưới
đây và bây giờ tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ
vẽ một đường ngang ở dưới thì chúng ta
vào s à set chúng ta chọn Line chúng ta
vẽ đường ngang ở dưới
này đấy tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ vẽ tiếp
là một cái đường l xuống theo như bài vẽ
xong
thì chúng ta có thể nhấn giữ Ctrl nhắp
kéo để copy qua các vị trí
này Nhấn vào dữ ctr nha nh nhắc kéo nha
đấy
à tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ vẽ ba cái đối
tượng hình chữ nhật có bo góc như thế
này thì chúng ta vào Insert à set và
chúng ta chọn hình chữ nhật bo góc nhắp
chột vào và chúng ta vẽ
lên đấy và sau đó chúng ta cũng nhấn
Ctrl Nhấn vào dữ Ctrl nhắc kéo để sao
chck
thì các bạn quan sát là trên này nó có
lịch này chúng ta có thể là dùng phím
mũi tên qua trái chúng ta dịch chuyển nó
để cho nó thẳng lại hoặc là phí m tên có
phải rồi bây giờ chúng ta chỉ việc là
nhắc Chốt vào chúng ta gõ dữ liệu vào
thôi Tuy nhiên á là
là cái phần gọi dữ liệu là mình không
minh họa nha Bây giờ là mình chỉ minh
họa cái thao tác này
n sau khi vẽ cái sơ đồ xong rồi thì
Nếu chúng ta đặt cái sơ đồ này chung với
văn bản á thì nó rất dễ xảy ra trường
hợp là các đối tượng này nó nó như
thế này đây thì cái trường hợp nó chịt
như thế là chúng ta rất khó xử lý và để
nó các đối tượng này nó tạo thành một
cái sơ đồ duy nhất á thì thực hiện Chúng
ta thực hiện một cái thao tác gọi là gom
nhóm các đối tượng và cách thực hiện như
sau chúng ta nhấn về dững phím shift lần
lượt chúng ta nhắp chuột lên các đội
tượng tất cả các đ đổi tượng đều phải
chọn cái thao tác này chúng ta cẩn thận
một chút vì chúng ta làm mà chúng ta
không
a nhập mà trật ra ngoài á thì nó lại bỏ
chọn cho nên đây mới nói xong như nó lại
bỏ chọn rồi đấy Làm lại nha Nhấn V dữ
shift lần lượt chọn các đội
tượng mình chọn các cái hình chữ nhật
xong mình chọn các cái À cái Line sau vì
cái thao tác chọn cái Line này nó cũng
rất là là khó thao tác vì là Đười tượng
Line này nó nhỏ
quá Khi nào con trỏ chuột có mũi tên bốn
hướng chúng ta hãy nhắp Đây nhắp Rồi
xong và xong thì chúng ta nhả chuột ra
bây giờ chúng ta gom thành một sơ đồ thì
chúng ta sẽ
vào S format chúng ta chọn lên group đây
l Group
đấy thao tác này là gom các đối tượng mà
mình chọn Á thành một đối tượng duy nhất
nhất đây khi thành sơ đồ rồi thì chúng
ta nhấp chúng ta kéo này nó đi luôn cả
sơ đồ được chưa và sau khi như thế này
xong thì chúng ta có thể định dạng nó
cũng được chúng ta vào set field chúng
ta chọn mà đấy mà hoặc chúng ta chọn bên
này chọn kiểm nên đó vừa nền và vừa vừa
chữ màu nền và màu chữ nha Bây giờ chúng
ta nh nhập chọn n tương tự như này đó
chúng ta chọn rồi và chúng ta có thể là
phòn chỉnh chúng ta gõ dữ liệu vào ví dụ
đây chúng ta gõ chữ là giám đốc công ty
giám đốc à v này chúng ta gõ vào là à c
phi dm
đất
đấy Các à thao tác tiếp theo thì tương
tự trường hợp mà ví dụ đây thì cái này
mà chúng ta gõ vào mà nó là không đủ độ
rộng nó rớp xuống như thế này thì Cách
thứ nhất Chúng ta mở rộng Cái ô này ra
mà nếu cái mở rộng ô này ra mà không
được thì chúng ta nên chúng ta chọn
Phong chữ nó nhỏ lại một chút đấy thì
lúc này là nó sẽ cho mình nó nằm gọn
trên một
dòng chữ có dấu tiếng Việt thôi bỏ qua
đi đó như vậy cách làm vậ á ha cò Nếu
chúng ta chọn muốn chọn màu sắc cho các
cái chữ này á thì chúng ta có thể vào
um chúng ta chọn này nữa đây và ph color
chúng ta chọn màu ví dụ chọn màu trắng
đây tương tự như vậy chúng ta có thể
chọn nhiều đối tượng cù lúc để chúng ta
chọn định dạng cho nó đấy và đó là thao
tác đội tượng hình vẽ và lưu ý các bạn
là cái thao tác với đối tượng hình vẽ
này Cái quan trọng nhất
á là chúng ta ta vẽ xong chúng ta phải
group lại thành một nhóm nha để chúng ta
dễ thao tác và trong các đối tượng hình
vẽ này này khi chúng ta vẽ có thể là ví
dụ chúng ta chọn cái hình chuyển nhặt bo
góc như thế này bây giờ chúng ta không
muốn nữa chúng ta muốn là đổi sang một
cái kiểu hình khác thì chúng ta cũng vào
SH format chúng ta chọn edit Shap và
chúng ta chọn là change Shap và chúng ta
đổi đổi kiểu đây rồi nó nó quay trở lại
cái cái hội thoại mà chúng ta chọn kiểu
Nã và chúng ta có thể đổi ví dụ chọn về
mục này đổi này đy thì cái hình này nó
sẽ quét bên đấy như vậy chúng ta hoàn
toàn có thể đổi hình lại nha rồi thì về
cơ bản thì các cái thao tác V đối tượng
hình vẽ là như vậy nha và chúng ta kết
thúc cái phần hướng dẫn các cái thao tác
và đối tượng h vẽ Xin chào các bạn